how's it going everybody so there has
been quite a bit of chatter today in
regards to the Avengers 4 trailer
possibly dropping on Black Friday this
week
now this is just a rumor for now and is
completely unconcerned however it does
come from two sources that have proved
reliable in the past so it's possible
also quick heads up still doing my
giveaway giving away a copy of the
infinity war art of the movie art book
infinity war Deadpool 2 or ant-man in
the wasp on blu-ray and some special
edition posters to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero
so Daniel are at Super bro movies has
reported that a very reliable source has
informed him that it's looking like the
trailer will land this Friday he did
however say that this is uncomfirmed but
a source did tell him this
the other is MCU cosmics Jeremy Conrad
who said that there are whispers of the
number 23 being spread around right now
and he as well said that this was of
course unconfirmed however it does make
sense for them to do this and Disney has
done in the past they did it in 2014
with the force awakens
they previewed it for the very first
time on Black Friday in 2014 so it makes
sense that they would do it they have
done in the past and these sources have
proved to be right in the past many
times again keep in mind that these are
just rumors and in the next week there
are probably going to be a lot more
rumors coming until we actually get the
trailer if I hear them I'll report them
to you in case one of them is actually
right that is until we officially get
the Avengers 4 trailer we do know it's
coming pretty soon so until then the
hype is real let me know how excited you
are for it in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff
[Music]